how much fun are you having in Vegas I
love Las Vegas Lauren anyways I'm here
to say one thing and one thing only
Boulton for bachelor not my bachelor
really you tell me why not you know
hello young he's younger than me he
might be more advanced in his life than
I am but I don't necessarily see him
marrying the woman that he chooses why
for a plethora of reasons give me a
couple one I don't think he knows
exactly what he wants to I don't think
he knows exactly what he wants three
what do you think he thinks he wants
versus what he actually want well you
thought on paradise right you saw him
say two lines of I am the person that I
think everyone wants me to be and the
public pressure to be someone is very
real on The Bachelor
well very real on the Bachelorette very
real and bachelor in paradise but even
more so ten times a hundred times on The
Bachelor and I think he'll do what he
thinks people will want him to do and
not what's necessarily right for him who
was your pick Jason blank oh my god you
know Jason and Blake both incredible
humans and both just as deserving if not
more deserving than all of us for love I
love kotha no get me wrong but not my
bachelor are you single Dean I am yeah
would you go on paradise or winter games
again in an ideal world I will find my
person outside of Bachelor
do you watch Colton season of course to
be a dumpster fire of course I'm gonna
watch it I imagined Colton season going
the same way mine would where he wants
to do right by everyone and he wants to
no one to hate him and that's going to
just go ahead and fight him right in the
butt but you would not be bachelor oh my
god I'd be a horrible bachelor for the
same reasons Colton be horrible and will
be horrible why do you think producer
shows him
he's a very nice person and he that's
why they chose him absolutely he's
well-intentioned he is beautiful I just
think it's gonna be a dumpster fire
[Music]